ils deviennent des stars grâce à la télé
française ils gagnent de l'argent grâce
aux Français qui les suivent sur les
réseaux sociaux et l'argent qu'il gagne
des sommes astronomiques on le sait tous
ils vont à Dubaï pour ne pas payer
d'impôts à leur patrie et la France
qu'on aime et qu'on respecte moi si le
Dubaï dégage les stars de téléréalité ça
me pose aucun problème je pense qu'ils
auraient bien raison c'est pas vrai déjà
il y en a qui ont des sociétés de
missiles en France ensuite moi
j'enquêtais effectivement vous pouvez
être expulsé de Dubaï si vous commettez
certaines fautes très graves un crime un
viol du trafic de stupéfiant vous êtes
automatiquement expulsé si on raye une
voiture
mais c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils sont
très durs là-dessus là en l'occurrence
ce sont des fausses rumeurs basés sur le
fait que ces personnes génèrent
énormément de jalousie qu'elles gagnent
beaucoup d'argent et qu'elles sont très
critiquées notamment par les Français
mais aucune de ces personnalités n’est
menacée d'expulsion c'est basé aussi sur
le fait qu'il y en a certaines qui sont
déjà partis et qui l'ont plus ou moins
annoncé Nabilla veut partir notamment
dans 3-4 ans aux États-Unis mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec ça donc c'est une
fausse rumeur basée sur la jalousie
moi je pense que quand on va habiter
dans un pays on doit quand même
respecter un petit peu la culture du
pays et la culture émirienne elle
respecte quand même les principes de
l'Islam c'est une culture qui est
traditionnelle qui va pas forcément avec
le stream ficelle avec l'alcool avec les
soirées tous les soirs donc moi ça me
paraît pas fou que peut-être certains
influenceurs qui abusent un petit peu
sur la fête sur alors en étant toujours
on a la chance d'avoir la spécialiste
non mais j'y pas une seule seconde c'est
elle a le string cordano
j'y crois pas
j'y
crois pas c'est tout bénéfice pour
l'image de doux et de Dubaï oui pardon
c'est tout bénéfice vous rendez compte
tout ce qu'ils font comme comme buzz
là-dessus et tout ça en quoi c'est un
bénéfice pour Dubaï bah attends l'image
qui donne malgré tout bah attends avec
tous les suiveurs et tout ça moi je
n'entends parler de Dubaï que par les
influenceurs ils s'en fiche complètement
des influenceurs
non plus comme dit j'ai Guillaume ils
ont pas tué père et mère donc je n'y
crois pas un seul instant c'est de la
pub oui pour le moment aucun influenceur
aucune influenceuse n'a reçu de lettres
mettant fin au visa c'est des visas
prolongés entre 1 et 3 ans aucun déguisé
juste il y en a deux dont on peut pas
donner les nombres parce qu'il y a une
procédure judiciaire contre qui eux
risquent l'expulsion mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec une volonté de Dubaï de virer
les influenceurs absolument pas moi je
pense que ça sent la fin malgré tout
alors oui bien sûr il y en a qui vont
tirer leur épingle du jeu comme la Villa
comme Maëva ouais mais je pense que
malgré tout moi je l'ai toujours dit je
pense que c'est une bulle spéculative
alors ils étaient ouais ils étaient en
France ils sont rackettés donc ils vont
à Dubaï à Dubaï ça va quand même mal se
passer pour quelques-uns donc ils vont
partir aux États-Unis donc je pense que
malgré tout c'est la fin d'un système
alors ils font d'autres choses ils se
réinventent autrement on a vu par
exemple ici ils font des max des matchs
de boxe donc c'est très bien mais je
pense que malgré tout on est un peu au
bout d'un programme d'abord les
programmes ne se regardent plus donc ils
sont juste influenceurs maintenant mais
moi j'y crois plus et je pense qu'il va
y avoir de moins en moins d'argent
il y a beaucoup moins d'argent en ce
moment on sait que les recettes là où il
y avait 300 ou 400000 euros par mois par
mois on est plutôt de diviser par 4
et puis c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
nouveaux arrivés gagnent plus du tout
d'oseille voilà plus du tout donc c'est
plus un eldorado donc ça va disparaître
ouais c'est possible